so uh we're gonna talk about
four things what is a type
the four modes of typing
some typing protocol examples and a
conclusion okay
so
what is a type
so this is a direct quote from pep483
the theory of type hints which was
written by gridophon hosum and Yvonne
Levitsky the kisky
so there are many definitions of the
concept of typing the literature here we
assume that type is a set of values and
a set of functions that one can apply to
those values
right
uh
for me my first understanding of types
was very Mo very much focused on on the
the set of values because you think
about oh okay so you have the set of
the complex numbers and then you have
the real numbers and then you have the
integers
and so on but that's in the beautiful
pure world of mathematics
in the real world
there are some small issues right
reality is complicated reality is more
complicated than math
so
I have an integer and then I convert it
to a float
looks alright except that one is not
equal to the other
right actually in the set of floats
there is no float that represents
precisely that number
and if you import the decimal module it
can when you when you when you create an
instance of decimal it shows you then
a string representation with full
precision
and as you can see they are not really
the same number although they are pretty
close right
uh
so yeah
a little side note it's interesting that
the float type
has been has been around for a long time
it's basically embedded in all modern
CPUs right the all the basic operations
with floats are embedded in the CPUs but
it's a type that is more useful to
scientists engineers than for people for
instance who deal with money right which
is I guess
most of us or many of us I don't know
so I I always thought sorry this was
kind of weird that uh
most mainstream languages don't have a
really good way of representing money
and people try to use float for that but
it's not great so decimal is an
alternative in Python to do that
but the set of values definition is not
useful for other reasons also because
python does not provide practical ways
to specify types as sets of values
except for a new
in practice in the standard Library we
have very small sets like the set of the
name type which has only one instance
none blue which has two instances
and then on the other hand you have
extremely large ones with billions of of
instances right
uh the inks and the string types for
example the the possible values are only
limited by
the the width of the pointer in the
machine
uh
so
and also we have no way to say for
instance that a quantity type that I
would like to use for instance in an
e-commerce application to validate that
orders are not placed with zero
of an item or more than a thousand this
could be an interesting safety measure
right usually it's rare that you order a
thousand or more of something in a
retail store
so you can't say that there's no way in
the in Python to say that in the type
system to express that right
uh for instance also there's no way to
say that our airport code is the set of
all these 17
576 three letter combinations of
uppercase ASCII letters
there's neither of those
sets can be expressed in the in the type
systems
uh at least not in the type systems of
mainstream languages and certainly not
in the type system of python
so in practice it's more useful to think
that int is a sub type of float because
it implements the same interface
basically the interface of float has to
do with arithmetic and all the
operations also apply to integers
right
and
but inks also have a few other methods
like for instance those that do bitwise
manipulation shifts right shifts left
things that wouldn't make sense in a in
a float
so that's the main reason why we we can
think of ink as a subset of not a subset
a type of floats because it implements
all the types all the the entire
interface of float and an additional few
methods
I put a couple of
asterisks here because just yesterday I
discovered there are a few float methods
that it does not Implement okay but
there's a kind of bizarre one of them is
one that generates a hexadecimal
representation of the
of the
of the fruit
but anyway as a good approximation we
can think of subtypes and in general
that's true for subtypes that they
implement the
entire interface of the super type in
addition to more methods right
uh
so for instance here I continue that
example by showing that the pipe
operator which is the bitwise ore you
can use it with an integer but you
cannot use it with a float right
and another example of how it's more
useful to think about the
the interface
is that in in Python's static type
system
we have now the any type and and
basically
because
any value can be assigned to an object
variable and any value can be assigned
to any variable you can say that you
know they are like the universe
types right uh but the the super
important difference between them
is that the object type implements a
narrow interface
right
pretty much every single most super
classes that we create from objects add
methods right that don't exist in
objects
uh
uh and with any on the other hand is
this magical type
that is required because of the because
of the nature of the gradual type system
that we have
which means that you know sometimes you
you may have a piece of code that is not
annotated
or you're using a library a third-party
library that is not annotated so you get
the results from there and all that the
the the type Checker can
infer is that the return is any
right and any satisfies every interface
is like this magical interface that
contains all possible methods that exist
today or that will ever exist right so
this is a crucial difference between
them
so in January if you think of of
subtypes
as sets you get
the the biggest set is in the top right
object is the set of everything and then
you go down down down to more specific
types more specialized type that usually
have fewer instances but on the other
hand the interface grows right at the
top of the our class hierarchy the
interface is narrower and as you go down
it gets wider more specialized and gets
more methods
mm-hmm
so from that definition of Pep 483 we
are going to adopt that point of view
that a set is a set of functions that
one can apply to those values a set is
defined by the set of functions that you
can apply to an object
right
and then here's another another quote
from
from small talk
and I'm not talking about small talk
just because I have a great beard I'm
talking about small talk because it's
really very it's the type system of
small talk is very similar to the type
system of python
and just like the type system of Ruby
and the type system of JavaScript
uh
and in the small talk Community they
they use this term protocol right so
this this this quote is from one of the
designers of small talk
every object in small talk even a lowly
integer has a set of messages a protocol
that defines the explicit communication
to which that object can respond
in small talk there was no explicit way
to declare a protocol
but some
browsers that you use to code to code in
small talk did present
uh
clusters of methods as a protocol
uh and of course a class could Implement
several protocols
so that was the way they used it more as
a as metadata for the programmer than
something that was checked right
so
the main takeaways from this first part
is that types are defined by interfaces
and protocol is a synonym for interface
right so that's where the name from the
the name of the typing protocol class
that we're going to talk about comes
from
foreign
typing
so last time I looked Alex Martelli
who is my friend and also one of the
reviewers of the first edition of my
book
is credited was credited by Wikipedia
for being the first person who used in a
written message
that you can find online
this black metaphor
I don't know if he invented it but he
was the first one who used it in a in a
python mailing list to talk about you
know to respond to a question about
polymorphism
that had to do with type checking python
you know many years ago when there was
no static typing right so the the idea
is that you don't check whether
something is a deck you check whether it
quacks like a duck or Walks Like A Duck
Etc depending on exactly what subset of
duck-like behavior you need
right
I started using python in 98 and at the
time there was no ABCs there were no
ABCs in the standard Library
so in the beginning I was a little bit
uh
mystified by the appearance of of
phrases like oh this function takes a
file like object okay what is that there
was no definition anywhere right
but it was a common practice to to have
these kinds of uh of Expressions I think
it's there's still uh phrases like that
in the documentation
a buffer-like object is another thing
that is super important for data science
there was a then there was some
formalization of what that means but uh
the interesting thing is the precise
meaning of a fire like object depended
on the context
right sometimes all all you needed was I
need something that has a read method
that returns bytes for instance
let's file like enough for me in this
moment
does that make sense
in another situation maybe you need
something that has a closed method and a
right method things like that right but
it was always very very informal similar
to how it was informal in in small talk
as well
so one definition that you can give if
somebody asks you what's the difference
between a
a protocol in an interface you know if
we are not talking about static typing
you can say that protocols traditionally
were informal interfaces that were not
defined explicitly in code but where but
uh where the code depending on
one of those interfaces
or on a few matters to do something
right so
for instance when I I I've taught python
to lots of people and most of my
students over time
came from a statically typed languages
like
Java mostly and
C sharp and so I always like to show
them this example of a very simple
function double
to illustrate duct typing right so I
create this single function double and I
can I can use it with a
need with a float
with a complex
with fractions
and those are all numbers but I can also
use it with sequences
right so
what is the
the idea here is what is the the
protocol that double expects X to
fulfill
double expects that the argument X is
able to multiply itself
by an integer
that's what is implicit in that code and
this is why all of those objects support
that because
under the covers they Implement a method
called
Thunder move
right
so blender double on this car in front
behind and
some special name
is the is the actually is actually the
method that's any class that you write
can Implement to support the
the multiplication sign this operator
right
now here's another example a more
dramatic example
so I have this simple class that
represents the train
okay and it's only attribute is a length
that is established when it's
constructed
and so then we have the Blended land
methods that Returns the length and we
have the Thunder get item methods
um
and basically checks whether the the eye
is uh within the range right from zero
to length minus one
and if it is then it returns a string
saying card number such and such right
otherwise it raises index error
so for instance
if I have a
if I build a train with three cars and I
ask the length of the train I get three
so this is the typing right notice this
class inherits
implicitly from objects there's no other
special class that I'm using here
so what makes something work with Len in
Python is
a
basically for buildings python has a
shortcut okay built-in and extensions
like extensions written in C or rosters
or other languages can Implement in in
those lower levels using this the python
C API what is called a slot
uh
uh that will respond to the Lane but
even if you don't do that there is also
you know some uh it's funny because the
C code of python is kind of object
oriented C okay not C plus plus
object-oriented C this kind of a nested
structures
uh in which the everything that has a
length everything that has multiple
items in it
Has a Field that python can inspect
immediately to know how many items there
are
okay so that's very fast because it
doesn't involve any method call but if
that field doesn't exist then python
will try and find whether there is a
dandelion implementation either in the
low level language or in Python if it's
a python object right so that's how lens
works
and it's
an example of black typing right
you'll need to inherit from anything to
implement to support Lane you just
Implement that method
the second example is
what triggers the don't forget item
method
right uh
and again another example of deck typing
but the third example is really dramatic
because
and
the the target of a for Loop uh in this
case the the T
is supposed to implement an interface of
iterable right
uh and how do you implement the
interface of interval formally you
implemented under ether methods
that returns an iterator which by which
is another interface that implements in
the next method
however I didn't implement the underator
here
okay
well anyway in regular in a regular deck
type of language you would any class
that would Implement then they really
would work for iteration but python goes
even further than that because that's so
fundamental uh iteration is so
fundamental to the language
and also to support legacy codes
it's it just so happens that uh the
python Machinery this is actually built
in the etherbutin function
the the attributing function
looks to see if the object implements
then they read but if it doesn't then
there is a fallback and the fallback is
does it Implement then they get item
and then it tries to send a zero you
know it tries to call then there get
item with a zero arguments and if that
works then it starts iterating by
providing more indexes until they better
get item returns index error right so
this is kind of an extreme example of
black typing right of the the Machinery
of the language trying to use the the
object even when the object doesn't
Implement one particular interface it
falls back to another interface and and
does what you expect right
mm-hmm
okay so now I'm gonna show the first
example of a of a protocol
and this I think is the best example of
a protocol in the in the whole talk
is the most similar to the kinds of
protocols that you are likely to use in
your
in your job
so what I'm saying here is I have a
function called run file and it takes
one argument called source file which is
a text reader
and then immediately above there's a
definition
right of a class that inherits from
protocol
right
and that definition is exactly like it's
like I wrote it here the the ellipse is
in line 203 is part of the syntax
okay
the Ellipsis is telling you that
um
the body is omitted instead of pass
which explicitly say says this doesn't
do anything
is what what this is saying is uh the
the body will be defined somewhere else
it doesn't matter what the body is
so in order to satisfy that uh that
protocol
an object any object in the world can
satisfy that protocol by implementing a
read method that returns a string
that's it
okay
so and often you you you you will see
code like that where the interface is
defined right above the place where it's
used
this is common we see that a lot in go
code and why am I talking about go code
because go is the first mainstream
language that that is statically typed
but also supports this idea
uh of declaring protocols
uh notice that
whatever class whatever class I use to
pass to to produce a text really doesn't
need to inherit and in fact they won't
inherit from text reader
all they have to do is to implement the
interface
okay
so
the benefits of using typing protocol
are that you can preserve the
flexibility of the typing
so you can let your clients know what is
the minimal interface expected
regardless of of class hierarchies
you can support static analysis
right Ides and linters can verify that
an actual argument
that appears in a cost site for that uh
run file function
doesn't does satisfy the the protocol
right and you reduce Club coupling
because the the client classes don't
need to subclass anything just implement
the protocol and this also makes testing
easier right because if you need to
create some kind of mock to test all you
have to do is Implement that one methods
you don't need to inherit from anything
right so let's talk about the four modes
of typing
we all know there's this Duality between
you know static typing Dynamic typing
and this has to do with when the types
are checked right static typing is
designed to support static checking
which is checking then by tools and
compilers and so on and runtime checking
is uh uh I mean Dynamic typing is it was
invented to support runtime checking
right
the authors of the of the type of the
typing spap promise that python will
remain dynamically typed okay
but actually the situation is more
interesting than this the situation is
that we have uh
this act this two axis
where
besides the static checking and runtime
checking we also have the the issue of
how the types are defined
or identified
so in static typing of languages like
Java
you have nominal types things belong to
a type because it's explicitly declared
you inherit from something or you
implement an interface right
but with like typing what we have is
structural types which means objects
belong to a type because they Implement
a certain interface
but they don't need to explicitly
declare anywhere that they do Implement
they just have to actually implement it
right
so these are like the two opposites
but this diagram actually has all other
other areas
this area Alex Martelli when he was
reviewing my first the first edition of
my book he invented this term Goose
typing
I'm not I don't have time to talk about
that
but basically that's the use of ABCs to
do explicit type checks at runtime
uh and then uh Lucas Langer and others
Lucas is speaking right now at another
room here they uh proposed pep for Pep
544 which implements structure of the
typing or the idea of I mean structural
super typing or the idea of static deck
typing right deck typing
static deck typing so
and that's supported by typing protocol
okay there are other languages that that
support things in those quadrants
see go appears in the static typing
quadrants
but also in the goose type in quadrant
because it has mechanisms for type
assertions at runtime and so on
okay so let's see some more examples
we were talking about the double
function how do we how could we annotate
that with a protocol
so can we do that
yeah okay this has a serious problem
the problem is the type Checker will
complain that the object type doesn't
Implement another move
does that make sense so this code
without looking at anywhere else the
type Checker knows that this code is
invalid
okay
can I use any yes but it's useless
because it's the same thing as no
annotation the any annotation pretty
much defeats type checking
you have to use it very carefully and
like an emergency exit
uh
I could do this and say that
X is a sequence of t
and here I have to introduce this idea
of the type VAR right because
sequences is a generic
abstract base class so I I'm saying this
if I get a sequence of of floats I'm
going to return a sequence of floats if
I get a sequence of strings I'm going to
return a sequence of strings this is
what the type variable is doing right
when the type Checker analyzes this it
gets a you know a concrete example of a
call site it looks at the type of the of
the of the elements in the sequence and
then it binds still to that type
and then it will and and infer that the
return is a sequence of that same type
okay
so this only works with sequences it
doesn't work with numbers
so the solution is to create uh
repeatable protocol
so the repeatable protocol is saying
that uh
is anything that implements then they
move and that takes a repeat count which
is an integer
okay and now I can say that X is a
repeatable and this returns a repeatable
are We Done Yet
no
because now when I call Double the
result that I get
is inferred to be something that only
implements on their move
and if you need to do other kinds of
operations with the object you won't be
able to the the type Checker won't let
you of course at runtime everything
happens right because that's the
characteristic of of the gradual type
system of python at runtime only the
dynamic types exist there's no
constraint but the type Checker will
point out that you know if you try to do
something else with this result know
this result only supports then they move
because that's what it says
so the way to solve this is a little bit
more involved you need to
to create another type of r so the
protocol is the same
okay the new thing here is this type VAR
here
and here I'm saying that
RT
can be bound to any type
but it has to be limited by I don't like
the keyword argument bounds I think they
should have used another word for this
maybe limited or upper bound or
something because there's this The
Binding of the variable and the bounds
which is kind of a a boundary right what
this is saying is that
we RT can only accept something that is
repeatable
but because of the way that this
variable is declared
the actual type of it will be preserved
as well
so if I if I pass a float
this will the the type Checker will be
able to infer first it will be it will
it will accept the float because the
float implements the little move and it
will
understand that this returns afloat okay
so that's one thing that we need to do
in this case
so when I discovered these things I was
doing research for the book and that was
the time of python 3.8 when typing
protocol was introduced
there's this project called type sheds
right which has the type of notations
for the standard library and other
projects and I I contributed several
fixes by by implementing protocols there
so for instance this there was this bug
that I found
that there's a uh the medium low the
medium low
function in the statistics module
actually works with strings with a list
of strings okay and there's an example
just like that in the documentation
so but it wasn't but at the time we had
a false positive which was that if I
pass if I submitted this code to a type
check it would complain and why is that
because the The annotation at the time
was saying that uh
the arguments had to be in iterable over
of number
and number was a type that they invented
there which was the union of ins
floating complexity or inflating and
fraction I think anyway it didn't work
with with strings they are not patient
although the function did work with
strings right so the solution was to
create this sortable uh protocol and
again you see the same formula that we
saw before right you have a protocol
and you have a type of R which is bound
to that protocol and then I can use that
type of r to say that Medium low accepts
an iterable of sortable t
which is the type the type of R bound to
sortable and it returns a sortability
right when I when I contribute that that
I looked around and I found many other
places in the python 3.9 standard
Library where we could improve the
annotations by using protocols
okay
and then there was the biggest challenge
for me at the time was the max function
the max function is super powerful right
like I said I've taught python many
times I never saw students say that oh
Max is super complicated to understand
no it's pretty simple you can pass it in
iterable
or a series of arguments and then if
it's an iterable then you it will return
the biggest item in the iterable if it's
a series of arguments we will find the
biggest of the of the arguments right
but then there is some optional
arguments and so on so it's very
flexible easy to use I like this API
okay but then somebody posted a bug
about that and I tried to fix it the old
type things were like that
so overloads is something that comes
this decorator comes from the typing
module and it's it's uh mission is to
allow you to to
do multiple type annotations to
different ways of invoking a single
function
right so it was already pretty
complicated my time is running up so I'm
not gonna
delve into the details here but this
wasn't working this was producing that
bug
that this person reported the bug was
that uh if you passed five and top where
top was none it exploded
and the solution was this
it took me several hours actually a
couple of days and with support of
people more experienced than I in the
type system to get to this
my first attempt had eight overloads
then
one of the maintainers of typeset showed
me how to simplify and reduce it to only
six
okay in order to do that because Max is
written in C I wrote it in Python
uh to test and so on and what caught my
attention was that my implementation was
shorter than the Declarations to satisfy
the type checker
okay
okay so there was a lot of stuff that
happened after that if you go look at
the code it's not like that anymore I
won't go into these details here but
it's just for you know for you to know
that with time super supports less than
became supports greater than and then
they invented another name and then they
created now what they are using is
supports Rich comparison which is a
union type of supports than their LC and
supports the energy which means that
in most of those functions that appear
in this uh
list here that have to do with ordering
stuff what they do is they accept the
current annotations accept something
that supports either less than or
greater than either way it will work
okay
there are some protocols in the standard
Library
most of them have to do with numbers
because unfortunately the numeric Tower
remember the numeric Tower it's
completely broken for use with type
typing and why because the Base Class of
the numeric Tower which is called number
has no methods which means that objects
of that class are useless you can't do
anything with them
so
but anyway so they invented those
uh
protocols that have to do with
where there's something supports a
conversion right and one of them for
instance I use in one example in the
book which is supports the index
supports index is a particular uh
protocol that means that the object
implements then their index
which as opposed to then there ain't
which floats also support
uh to convert to inks then they're uh
then their index is supposed to be
implemented only by integral types so
for instance if you use numpy all the
integral types of numpy supports
implement the gender index method so
they can use be used as indexes
okay so to summarize
uh
I recommend that you use typing protocol
to build pythonic apis
in fact
you can see that the standard library is
very pythonic although there are parts
of it that I don't consider very
pythonic but most of it is very pythonic
and the standard Library really cannot
be annotated without the use of typing
protocols right so you should use typing
protocol because then you can support
the typing with type hints and the type
is the essence of Python's data model
and standard Library
this allows you to follow the integrated
segregation principle the i in the in
the solid principles which means that
client codes should not be forced to
depend on methods that it does not use
you know I remember when I used the code
in Java sometimes you have to implement
methods just to satisfy the compiler
right
and this is a recommendation that I
learned from studying goal okay
uh
brought narrow Protocols are the best
okay most protocols that come in The
Ghost and the library have only one
methods and that's how your protocol
should should do as well that's why
trying to think of an interface in terms
of an ABC or a Java interface with the
many methods is not a good way of
getting started with designing a
protocol okay
closing words I have to say these things
and every time that I talk about python
typing okay
being optional is not a burger or
limitation of python type hints
it's the feature that gives us the power
to cope with the inherent complexities
annoyances flaws and limitations of
static types so please do not decide in
your team that everything has to have
type hints always
okay that's the only way to use a type
checking this is in the strictest
possible mode this is really bad it's
like deciding that every code has to be
a hundred percent test covered no 95
percent is good enough a lot of times
okay
so that was my talk
thank you so much I don't know if we
have time to go for questions maybe one
question yes